Wow
all right we had a guest in studio
coming in its that Greyhound breakdown
now people been in the irony and
Greyhound breakdown is that grounds
breakdown all the time you know me i
troll greyhound helped twitter feed all
the time some you know i'm on there at
night catching in seeing who's stranded
outside of Murphysboro you know seeing
who's stuck in the snow outside of
Narragansett you know i'm saying oh
there's always somebody there's always a
shooting on a greyhound somewhere you
know there's always something exciting
happening and so I'm always out there on
the feed I'm trolling that feed so we
had so many calls so many responses to
the Greyhound breakdown that I I'm
already gonna let you know we're gonna
do it again but the guy we got coming in
today he was a little nervous
it took us a while to get him in but he
definitely made it in and we're excited
to have him here in just a moment I want
to tell you guys first though that this
episode is brought to you by grey block
pizza and this is a menu that they keep
in their store and I took a menu and
they got everything they got salads
calzones they got them salad pizzas you
can't sure if you want salad or pizza
pizza or salad will get that space Aled
you feel me
they got that baby em salad the Caesar
and the G be chopped so they got all
types of special salads great block
pizza 18:11 Pico Boulevard on the way to
the beach as well this episode is
brought to you by the ridge and the
ridge have these groovy new I'll tell
you about it right now it's a minimalist
front pocket some people carry a wallet
in their back pocket you see sometimes
an old man have a huge wallet looks like
one of those Big Macs you know when it
come back on the menu and he just he
can't walk he has scoliosis wallet
weighs 30 pounds you know in the other
pocket he's got the ashes of his wife a
past or whatever and that's not safe so
don't end up like that man the thing you
gotta get is the ridge
you can reevaluate your everyday carry
it's launched by a father-son team and
found it on Kickstarter in 2013 to the
tune of two hundred sixty-six thousand
dollars a lot of men carry around
pointless stuff but the
helps you minimalize that it's a nice
little holder it straight up it's a
holster so suddenly you not just some
guy carrying around a thing of you know
old condoms high school pitchers hair
somebody got a little bit of somebody's
hair dude because you that pervert maybe
an old pair of panties my cousin keeps
an old pair of you know skunk hitters in
his wallet so everybody's got something
special in there no more this ain't a
scrapbook minimalize get efficient and
that's what the ridge does talk about
how sleek it is it's so sleek it's got
two metal plates bound together by a
durable elastic band it looks nothing
like a traditional wallet you can carry
it in your front pocket it's made out of
titanium carbon fiber aluminum special
options that keep you on the cutting
edge you're gonna be the Robocop of
finances and wallet tree the ridge is a
minimal front pocket wallet designed to
let you ditch your bulky wallet so if
you see a bulky wallet somewhere on the
ground just know that that somebody
didn't drop it they left that and moved
over to the ridge I got mine I like mine
they got dope backpacks you could check
those out too and you can get 10% off
today with free worldwide shipping so
say you move to Guam or you get
extradited you could still get your
order just going to Ridge or idge wallet
dot-com / Theo t-h-e oh that's Ridge
wallet dot-com / Theo and using the
promo code th EO for 10% off ditch your
bulky wallet today and get the ridge at
Ridge wallet calm and I know you guys
don't want to hear all these ads and
stuff but we got to pay the bills this
the last one
now you might if you're seeing me on the
YouTube or if you're not I'm wearing a
special top and you know you don't see a
lot of men blouses out there that are
special you know for men and make men
feel special and you do see a lot of you
know at dinner time you know a man is
supposed to wear you know something
nicer lunchtime he could wear whatever
he wants wife beater topless or
lunchtime attire but you never know what
a man's supposed to wear to breakfast
until now now you can go to breakfast
shirts calm and you can get this
beautiful
top that I have and this one has
avocados on it or I got this and this
one boy you know I'm saying this is this
is everything you could do your arms
like this in it and just feel that
guacamole under your armpits there's a
beautiful top and the beauty of them is
is that these are for breakfast you show
up to breakfast and you don't you don't
wear any [ __ ] anymore you wear
something that's made to enjoy breakfast
in and you can go to breakfast shirts
calm and use the code Theo von th EO vo
in and the beautiful thing is these are
from Australia so you're getting a
breakfast shirt that has really been
around the world and probably made by
criminals because Australia's created
from criminals British prisoners let's
be honest dude you know I'm saying these
ain't upper echelon and they are out
there so in shirts now and they want us
to get them and I got one and I enjoy
mine man it's nice you can wear it
anywhere your breakfast is served you do
breakfast at night wake up and put this
[ __ ] on and you'll love your breakfast
shirts com discount code th EO vo in now
the price might a little bit look a
little high because that's Australian
dollars so you got to break that down
into American dollars and know what's
goin on and and that's natural but you
can go to breakfast shirts calm and get
one and then the code Theo von for 10%
off that beautiful hitter and uh and
they're nice man and this is a medium so
if you wonder what I'm wearing I'm a
medium I'm a lean guy six foot about 178
pounds alright now let's get into our
guest this dude been out there riding
the rails he's silent but deadly just
like a lot of the smells on on greyhound
welcome to the first greyhound break
down ladies and gentlemen
[Applause]
you know I just happen to been a you
know I frequented the Hound over the
years and I know you work with him yeah
so I'm trying to find out I just want to
get to know what it's like we'll get to
know you a little and that's it okay you
know we're happy that you're here
I appreciate it yeah yeah I'm a little
I'm actually really nervous are you
really yeah man dang already nervous is
my first time kind of being on camera
yeah doing something like this but I'm
excited I think you're hilarious oh
thanks man I appreciate it yeah you know
you're pretty big fat I mean I wouldn't
say I'm yeah be honest with me what are
you I'm not I'm not the like probably
you're big as you just fan writing but
but you know I'm sure there's a lot you
know better fans and things like that
but I think you're hilarious I first got
a got introduced I guess to you through
the the fighting kids product I [ __ ]
own Ice Man so I think it was you and
Brendan and they moved right through
here no way yeah they're not here today
that's crazy but this was their old
studio you know that yes yeah yes so
this is it I mean that's advocating
fight call you might have seen that in
there before and their thing that's
tears yeah this is their thing that's
crazy yeah that's crazy
um yeah we're sitting here with on Hill
on Hill um I go by angel but I'm hell
angel that's cool like if you're in a
gang which one is it if I'm in a gang
yeah man whatever but like is on Hill or
angel is that more of a gang name on
Hale it seems like a gang like on Hill
didn't do it you know yeah I guess I
guess you could say that or angel also
maybe angel angel either or either one
either yeah cuz your name like would fit
in good in a gang like money I'm like
Theo isn't it really in a gang you know
I'd have to get a nickname uh-huh well
you could go into a gang straight up
with your natural name that's kind of a
blessing I think maybe yeah
yeah it could be actually either or
angel I've there's there's it can be a
boy groan aim yeah very versatile but
it's a good name with the ladies because
you get to like you know you immediately
that you it's already think you already
have a pickup line a little bit I'm sure
you can make a pickup line off of that
for
but but you don't saying like I'm your
angel like you already have like a lit
must be nice that does it help with the
ladies you think instead of being like
Bart yeah yeah maybe Bart yeah yeah I
mean I'm in a relationship now right so
I'm sure she kind of liked it this is
angel you know this is uh yeah yeah oh
yeah maybe probably probably yeah I hope
so
so you're an operator man you are a
motorcoach operator yes is that the
correct term motorcoach operator yeah
driver driver and you've worked you work
for Graham but you have I have yes yes
in the past I've worked for a few years
a few years I didn't have a really long
stint with Greyhound I got with them or
I was employed with them at a very young
age I'm 26 now take really you were
employed with Greyhound at at the age of
about 20 22
what 22 years bro yeah 22 yes yeah I was
really young really I got my commercial
license pretty young at a pretty young
age so um is that crazy like getting on
there and being like holy [ __ ] I'm in
charge of all the a people no it is it's
really interesting for sure to say the
least to be as a driver that young
dealing with a lot of different people
yeah different age groups different
walks of life yeah you know it was an
eye-opener oh you get it all on there
I mean gray on is basically like it's
like one of Dante's like circles of hell
kind of traveling around America
sometimes you know yeah I can be where
I'm from anyway it would be water you
know you'd have like a nice little old
lady going to see her you know her
grandson's graduation you'd have a
couple do just got out of prison for
some reason they always put them on the
bus like what yeah no they will put like
literally put them on the bus yeah and
is there like training so that you know
like when a prisoner gets on how to
behave yeah well not not uh you know
prison training but per se but they
definitely go through a thorough
training program before they really let
you
your own date it's about a good two
months almost so it seems like about two
months training before they let you
loose and you know you're on your own
driver so like if you're gonna pick up
an inmate right because because now with
is they just basically a lot of times
the the correctional center or whatever
we'll just give those guys they serve
their time they get a bus ticket yes how
far is the ticket usually do you even
know typically um no no no you don't
really know you know you you get the
ticket and they're pretty much going
wherever their destination is you know
now when they get on do you have like a
chat with them kind of like you know
whenever like you're in grade school and
like the bad kid gets on the you know
the driver is always like hey look you
know keep it together do you do that or
no yeah you do you do and that's pretty
much goes I guess across the board with
with with the majority of the passengers
I would say because when you first get
that ticket you want to kind of kind of
gauge them a little bit kind of want to
gauge them and kind of fill them out you
know I guess that that's a one of your
first contacts with the passengers is to
when you get that ticket yes right
because you come off to coach mm-hm and
you get everybody's ticket that's
waiting right there as they enter yes
okay yeah now at that point are you kind
of like have you ever had to stop
somebody right there me like nah yeah
come yeah
really for what like what kind of stuff
um cuz I know some savage [ __ ] happens
on the ham bro yeah yeah one major thing
would be like body odor oh really yeah
yeah if a passenger kind of you know has
as a stink you know to them oh yeah that
Senate passenger yeah that dark artist
but they can't be in there [ __ ]
stanking up the head that's crazy and
what kind of smell is is body odor is
its body over man its it's probably
urine or they you know haven't showered
in a couple days maybe yeah the crazy
thing about urine is the smells okay in
the beginning bro you make a [ __ ] hot
you got a hot batch of urine mm-hmm that
first hit is kind of sugary or whatever
but after day to your sour you right
right from is one thing I can kind of
give a little bit of credit to ground is
that at that particular one they gave
that passenger
shower oh really they did yeah they were
able to take that passenger to shower
them up and then you know go on a later
later it was a lot that's pretty cool
that was that one of the major terminals
where they have that option you know a
lot of terminals you know the smaller
towns they may not have that option yeah
so in some places there is really I mean
there's a lot of humanity I think yeah
it depends on that I guess a lot of it
depends on the driver you know where
you're at I personally can't speak for
all agree on drivers yeah but from my
experience I definitely took pride in my
job
ya know was it scary say like a couple
of straight inmates right a couple of
just straight bangers getting on the bus
right because here's the craziest part
about your job they get on you have to
let them turn your back on all of them
mm-hmm and just start driving it's like
you're trying to get away but they're
all coming with you you know yeah it was
that scary sometimes yeah but at this
end also you got a I mean they're just
people also right of course and but I
mean specific like once in a while if
you got somebody on was it scary to like
turn your back a little bit yeah it was
a little bit scary I'm not gonna lie you
know but but most of the time it's
normal most the time it's it's a little
bit normal man yeah yeah I mean you also
have a rear view mirror oh yeah
definitely want to always position that
mirror where you can that you can see
the the walkway there's a walkway the
path towards the end of the bus you want
position that in a good position that
you can see the you know the top of the
heads yeah and would you see some stuffs
going on sometimes where you it you just
wouldn't you some of it you're like okay
I intervene here some of you like I
don't intervene yes yeah it's a
judgement call
yeah a judgment call for sure you know
there's one time I heard somebody you
know sleeping their toenails or
something like that and I was like man
that junk shop or voice somebody out
there chip-chop in the other life yeah
exactly so like okay you know how to
make an announcement
and that's another thing too you have
that mic yeah those those Greyhound
drivers they have the mics that go to
the back of the bus mm-hmm so you wanna
make a quick announcement hey
you guys want to stop that you know
chip-chop yeah you know do you call
people out specifically you make it a
vague announcement like hey if
somebody's cutting their nails stop or
will you say lady and wrote for you know
with the neck brace I'm trying to clip
your nails up like you make it specific
organization I'll say like whoever yeah
I'll say like whoever's kind of toenails
cuz I can't really technically see them
you know I die but right something like
that yeah
and a lot of complaints I would bet come
up to the front like people come up and
complain about something else yes yeah
and that typically is like at a stop
like maybe like a rest stop or a meal
stop they'll be like you know hey you
know pull me aside or something
everybody's getting snacks whatever and
they'll be like hey this person is doing
this or this than that so I'm doing what
drugs or something usually err um cuz
I've seen it all on the bus you know and
I'm not saying your bus specifically
yeah and I'm not trying to make you put
you in a weird spot but I've seen it all
out there yeah you know dudes offering
to blow me dudes one dude offer to blow
me for cocaine I'm like I don't have any
cocaine right yeah then he gave me some
cocaine and I'm like this is like a
reverse psychology I think you know I
don't even know yeah and B no bruh you
know I don't want either one of these
that's crazy man so you see I saw an
inmate one time get on he just gotten
out of jail he done 16 years two stops
later he's getting a snack he gets in a
knife fight with a dude in a parking lot
he gets really dry back you know like
he'd only been like 40 miles yeah damn
bro you got a you got a tight dang
that's crazy then you have a lot of wild
stuff happen cuz right now where was
your route you I mean I don't want to
disappoint you man but honestly I my
Greyhound experience wasn't it wasn't
horrible you know to me like I've heard
about different things you know about
happening stuff like that drugs and
things like that of that sort but but
yours was good now where was your route
I think that could have a lot to do with
it well I draw I drove out of downtown
Los Angeles Wow
drove out to Los Angeles and I would I
would travel you know about an hour to
work so yeah I mean and you would drive
to work out of out of downtown LA they
they you know have a lot of different
routes yeah and go oh yeah now what was
it now yours would change every day was
it just a day would you be on the road
for a couple days like what was that
like so how it works when you first get
on the Greyhound is basically your honor
your honor on a board with a bunch of
different drivers and whatever route
comes up you know if you're figuring the
line you're next up to take that route
and you'll take that route and is that
you get a new route each week or
something or each day or is it just you
get that route for a few months how does
that work okay so like let's say you
know I show up for work you know hey
they gave me a call you're going to
Arizona you know so I go in you know
take that route from from downtown LA
and then from from from LA you can go
like I said Arizona you'll have multiple
stops and from Arizona you can either
you know come back to Los Angeles or
they can even send you further east okay
you know Texas or things of that sort so
kind of whatever pops up that's where
you go yeah yeah there are certain
drivers you know once you have I guess
tenure tenure right time served
yeah I'm served with greyhound routes do
pop up for drivers and you're able to
bid on those routes and let's get them
go get a more solid schedule
I see cuz you really don't have a
schedule once you start off with
greyhound and that's works that's that's
a lot of transit you know drive driving
that's kind of how it goes yeah it's
kind of free-range it's kind of like
stand-up comedy in that sense like you
don't you know you kind of have to take
what's given to you you know when you
start now like you know you got to do a
gig in Toledo you got to do a gig I did
a get a shoe shoe store one time during
a day okay knowing some [ __ ] big
broads fitting into trying to fit into
some size fives you know yeah and you
know she's not gonna make it in there
I'm still got I hit these punched lines
you know and so it's you know I think I
think every job kind of starts out like
that and I'd love to get
I'm just trying to get a little bit more
into cuz you went out look at you look
so young I cannot even in Matt like if I
got on a bus and you were the motor
coach the captain you know you know how
would be like what yeah a lot of that I
really a lot of that yeah and just that
though because I have such a young
younger looking face yeah that I've
gotten that with with everything you
know like where my jobs now you look so
young
you mean the job that I currently drive
now you know I'm still one of the
youngest persons at at you job my job
yeah and now what was one of the wildest
things you saw when you were riding
might ham brownie you're you know going
ham what was one of the wildest things
you saw I guess one of the wildest
things I've been broken down and that
kind of pretty oh yeah that sucked
pretty bad we were going up north or we
might have been coming from the north
back to LA and we broke down an Avenue
that's one of their main like stuff that
they do along the five okay that's a
busy stop huh yeah broke down at the
station broke down just before the
station like I like the exit before if
they were pissed or what people were
pissed yeah there was babies on the bus
it was bad it was really bad and being
so far out it's kind of hard to get a
driver to come in you know rescue you
yeah so they had a driver from Fresno
come out and rescue from there because
that's another place where drivers drive
out of this Fresno mm-hmm that was a
previous great situation luckily it was
ours we had to wait hours and you know
got cold winded up there's a subway
there at the Avalon station uh-huh so uh
they coordinated with subway and
everybody got sandwiches oh really they
took care of them like that yeah Wow
that's pretty cool yeah so there's a lot
of goodwill that happens out there yeah
yeah and what type do you find that any
type of particular type or demographic
or ethnicity of people or cause the most
trouble Don Greg hunter as if what kind
of whatever oh you never know who it's
gonna be or what's it like yeah that's a
good question
[Music]
I would say I would say maybe foreigners
yeah I would say foreigners yeah kind of
I don't know if it's just the culture or
how they you know deal with things maybe
I don't know like how foreign you mean I
don't know maybe just you know they
don't necessarily speak English right so
people don't speak English probably it's
a little bit tough for anybody they
don't speak English sure like maybe
confused they can't even yeah discuss it
with you you get people under they think
it's like you know maybe like an older
person have been on there like 40 years
and they think it's like gonna be this
ride like it used to be back in the day
yeah and they don't realize it's just
she can be more savage on there yeah
yeah it's just it's really hustle and
bustle with greyhound you know you get
to a stop I remember one time down pass
anyway like Calexico mm-hmm that was one
of our crazy stops and a lot of people
missed their their transfer so they
they're trying to get on the next bus
which was oh yeah so I'm I'm stuck with
the job you know of having to you know
decide who gets to get on this bus damn
it's like the end of Titanic a little
bit yes it's like man you just picking
people you know what do you pick based
on honestly you picked the hotties first
or what no man I pick up based on their
time of their sometimes they have it
earlier whoever has the earlier time
okay off of whoever has first of all I
take all the people that have you know
tickets for that specific writers and
then just whoever comes or you know
right after that and now if you like do
you give if somebody seems like they're
more like you know they got their [ __ ]
together you liable to take them than
somebody it just seems like probably
yeah yeah yeah if someone has their bags
ready to go hey man I got my ticket then
yeah like oh this guy this person's on
that go exactly um did you ever catch
kids [ __ ] or anything like that on
the bus man cuz I remember I went to
Disney World one time and this was uh we
were Greyhound but it was we were it was
not during the regular service it was
like you know we'd paid for the buses
extra you know something or just rented
out some motor coaches okay and so me
and my girl ended up making love on the
way down there you know yeah someone if
you see a lot of that stuff
a lot of young lovers out there no not
too much
yeah mm-hmm actually no never yeah I
would think you would see that sometimes
yeah
damn man yeah I mean me actually me and
my girl we we we rode the bus together
we didn't we didn't do any you know
sexual things on there but uh but yeah
you know the girl that I have I'm in a
relationship now yeah I would be able to
you know not not she would invited me
during the work we're business hours but
it's called deadheading so basically you
take a bus to let's say Las Vegas right
it's completely empty okay so with
Greyhound you're able to sometimes ride
with family okay
so we got to take advantage of couple
you know take advantage of that option a
couple times so you and her would ride
up there just deadhead and go to Vegas
yeah oh that's fun man yeah it was fun
nice stuff and where'd you meet this
lady that your that your senior high
school sweetheart oh really man yeah so
you that young lover bro
high school sweethearts you hear that
young lover man I like ten years in man
really yeah
Wow ten years and and you just you've
been in love with her since high school
yeah yep and you guys have children or
no yes yeah we have a son oh that's
awesome yeah he's a year and a half oh
that's awesome dude I really appreciate
you coming today and take some time away
from your family I know it's Sunday no
problem what about this man let's take
some calls do cuz we got some calls cuz
obviously your experience with the
ground I think has been probably one of
the upper echelon experiences you know
um let's put these things I want to see
that hat man you got he brought that
hitter today bro he brought that
headpiece so on hello I want you to put
that headpiece on man and we can go like
this
all aboard baby
that thing's beautiful bro yeah man let
me check that thing out boy or can I
wear or we go you think that's okay all
aboard dude now how do you wear it um
cuz I got a big dumb one domed up yeah
I'm polish Nicaraguan brother Sam
got that down how is this good looks
beautiful look beautiful there you go
alright let's take a couple of calls I
want you to respond to some of these
calls with me and just see what you
think we're gonna and these aren't from
your route or anything he's from around
the way but these are all people that
have gone hound and had an experience
okay let's go see it with Sutton their
names Sully Sully huh and I was gonna
fly home as freshman year of college I
was gonna fly home but I think those two
expenses so my parents were like don't
take that greyhound and I was like
alright I took the greyhound and I can't
[ __ ] robbed on the Greyhound dude you
know in exodus dude and he [ __ ] pulls
out a gun literally stay right next to a
pulls out it goes tells me to empty out
boy empty out he took my wallet my cell
phone pretty much everything I had in my
pocket all my pockets and yeah he took
everything and the [ __ ] shitty part
was it was 15 minutes into a [ __ ] six
hour long bus ride this dude [ __ ]
robbed me I didn't know what to do and I
was like so I just sat next to this guy
to do the rest for the last six you know
for the remainder of the [ __ ] bus
trip and no one just do rustic and I
just walked yeah got the Baltimore just
like you walked up I didn't know what
else to do so I got [ __ ] rods 15
minutes into a six-hour bus trips okay
and the dudes enemy has the [ __ ]
decency to do it you know towards the
tail end where don't be awkward for five
and a half hours so yeah [ __ ] Greyhound
bro okay hell man what you buddy you got
a safe with that man because man um what
do you say to that
what do you say that passenger when he
comes to the front of the bus you know
then he got robbed
yeah man uh that yeah that's that's I'm
not sure to say about that man that's
crazy
you never said like I said fortunate man
that's really unfortunate yeah
now wishy what do you tell them to do
just file a complaint with their company
uh yeah man I would have to honesty I
don't have to be there man to be honest
with you I'm out what would you do in
that situation what I'm saying the
situation has occurred you know do got
robbed 15 minutes in like this 6-hour
attorney I would have to have a
conversation man that's it just like we
are now hey man what's up like what's
going on yeah we're gonna you know have
to you know solve it somehow would you
frisk the passenger what can you do that
kind of stuff uh no no no I would never
I wouldn't I wouldn't frisk him no you
asked him to turn the stuff in if he has
it yeah for sure and if he says he
doesn't have would you kick him off the
bus or let him keep riding well I mean
man there's a firearm on the bus you
know that's that's a is a firearm well I
mean he said he got robbed at gunpoint
oh yeah so there's a firearm on the bus
man that that's that's risking everybody
else's life man so not that much so on a
great you know saying if you don't I
think if you roll on the ground with a
family of five or six dude somebody's
catching a bullet you know what I'm
sayin somebody gettin slugged up I mean
it's wild but can you even imagine that
do you just sit down maybe you you know
coasted into a bag of chips you know
you're coasting into a little sack of
barbecue hitters next thing you know a
do pose a cold piece on you yeah and
then robbed you and you have to sit
there the whole time
imagine how bad your chips taste have
you been [ __ ] robbed and the dude
still now he's wearing your [ __ ] you
know he'll he moved all his money and
[ __ ] into your wallet he's carried your
damn yeah that's crazy man man yeah I
cannot even fathom that I do remember
when I was on gram one time a dude said
you want to see something hmm and I
thought it was gonna be his dick you
know honestly cuz you know a lot of
dudes in there flashing a meat yeah and
next thing I know he opened up he had a
bag of jewelry and a gun you know he'd
robbed a jewelry store oh and uh and he
was going home man yeah so a lot of dark
artists riding there yeah for sure do
you think you didn't know what was going
on a lot of times you think you didn't
have those types of people mmm as far as
like what do you mean like I mean
they were like they got gunplay in the
back yeah
yeah I don't know I don't know to be
honest with you yeah sure this is that
next car then let's hit that next call
all aboard
hey what's up - Devon this is Katie from
Louisiana ooh
you ever been Indiana no ma'am
made love to two girls once how many
other were cousins they said they were
okay but I think a lot of times girls in
an animal lie and say that just to get
you to make love to both of them you
know onward I happen to sit next to very
interesting she definitely had a like
black and purple dr. Seuss high and then
he actually had like a dr. Seuss shirt
that said like one fish two fish red
fish blue fish second okay so somebody's
got Aryan obvious I like white I want
like white they're like stated like
really light denim but his balls were
totally just like right there you could
see him just just right there and so I
thought next to him the whole way from
India announcer Toledo and superceded is
how this 14 year old girl about his
about his relationship about his
relationship with what underwear that
didn't frickin do their job you hear
that yeah she said she sat next to a guy
dressed as a cat in the hat' right and
he had his nuts out yeah
and he was talking about a 14 year old
kid about his relationship yeah what do
you say to that passenger you know again
man no it's crazy it's crazy man okay
what do you say like this is just like
right now man yeah no solution that we
exactly exactly you guys keep going
right Zach named a man I like it I like
it
damn that's crazy that cat in the head
did you see a lot of people in costume
no no no yes sir you work for Greg yeah
bad yeah Wow all right
all aboard let's get this next calm
and thank you for being here on Hillman
yeah no problem no problem hey Theo this
is Craig from Canada
oh right Craig from Kennedy did you ever
drive it's Canada no yeah have you been
to Canada or not
no do you do well in like a cold weather
you know are you a cold weather guy you
think yeah yeah yeah yeah like a weather
there you go let's hear it huh when I
was 15 I was coming back from Nova
Scotian Ontario and there was a 40 year
old woman on the bus with me and she had
two kids it was a two-day bus ride ride
she was telling me telling me about how
she left her husband and how she he was
cheating on her and he was abusive and
[ __ ] I was just young I wanted to stop
su-mei they traveled all night wanted to
stop see made she woke me up and told me
to watch a kid I didn't hardly knew this
woman she ducked out and came back with
the 26 or of whiskey and started
drinking getting receded he got pretty
drunk on the bus
Frank raised in the morning and the next
stop that we hit her husband was waiting
at that stop for we were already in
Quebec so we were already a province
away from where we started he drove all
that way and met her on the bus and all
hell broke loose so I was only 15 I
don't know what the [ __ ] to do I was a
much younger than her older than the kid
she was traveling with so what'd she say
right there on Helmand we got a domestic
dispute outside of the bus what do you
do like what's the protocol uh domestic
abuse separate them you know you get out
yelling if a passenger gets off and they
get into fight outside of the bus do you
deal with that or that's just you leave
that out in the world and you just gotta
go no I mean it depends also on the
passengers you know a lot of times the
passengers you know won't let things go
down you know if a man is trying to beat
up on a woman yes that's there's a good
wall probably I mean I would think so
you know defend a woman yeah so a group
of men so a lot of times this stuff
happens on the bus it's kind of its own
little world yeah and things that will
kind of solve themselves so if like
somebody's being wronged as somebody
else the other passengers will kind of
like they will hold court
in a way uh-huh yeah you know what
that's really true I'd notice that too
man I noticed if you got going because I
would ride all the time and I would ride
all the time dude to visit girlfriends
and its riding around the South right up
to rode up to Chicago from New Orleans
one time you know you're on those
overnight trips and you know you just
kind of see what goes on and you know
you got all kinds of people on there you
got the mother that you know maybe
things didn't work out with the man and
she's got her baby you know and yeah you
know they're trying to go somewhere and
they don't have a lot of money you know
and they don't want to go back they
don't want to stay where they are
because that's where the man is in that
town you know and you'll have like a kid
that's on their first trip ever you know
leaving maybe to go to school or to go
visit a grandparent or something you
know you got a kid taking that first you
know 15 16 years old look like on their
first adventure you'll have a you know
you got a lot of poor families that you
know this is for them this is flying for
them this is you know somebody maybe is
on a five-day trip they're going to
Disney World you know and the kids don't
know that the same first class they
don't know that you know you know that
mom saved you know this is this is their
vacation so to them this is the greatest
thing yeah so you got a real microcosm
of people on there and you know and then
you also got people that's just wild and
people that's just doing whatever and
live in willy nilly mm-hmm but I think
it's almost like a sample of a mayor of
the world you know a little bit it's
like yeah and problems gonna work
themselves out yeah did you ever see any
fights go down no really no fights man
fights yeah I mean honestly I I mean I
think a lot of they have to do with the
driver really yeah
now some drivers one driver one visited
his girl one time we're all sitting out
there on the bus yeah outside of
Birmingham we all sit on this bus for
two hours he's inside with his [ __ ]
side piece yeah I know this lady missing
the net was her name I remember that
we're out there looking in this lady's
yard and [ __ ] some do pissed in this
lady's birdbath you know we out there
playing games yeah getting this lady's
yard yeah and he's in there what is lady
yeah I think a lot of it has to do with
a driver man how they
dang I forgot I was reading this book
and the author kind of basically was
given this mindset on you know when
you're on that bus as a driver that's
your that's your f and bus yeah I know
what I mean and you know whatever goes
down on that bus is is uh is a lot of it
has to do on you it's a lot of
responsibility right you set the tone
exactly there are a lot of drivers that
are just kind of doing whatever the
thing playing about a roll a little
sloppy yeah you know you can kind of
tell how the uniform is you know you got
untucked shirt or extra chili in a
pocket yeah exactly the exactly stuff
like that you know the the people will
feed off of that
yeah so they come on in like all this
dudes [ __ ] up then I'm a [ __ ] yeah
and not to toot my own horn horn or
anything but I've gotten a lot of
compliments over the you have you really
yeah yeah oh man you're one of the best
green well yeah and no but I could see
that there's something about you that
it's kind of a peaceful nature and it
makes you you have like a semblance of
where you know cuz you got like you know
you were gonna come today at 3:00 you
got here you know you decided you know
if we were gonna come and then finally
you know you agree you're gonna come in
and I know you were nervous you know and
uh and I was like at first I was upset
you know I was like oh wow he's not
comin like you know we'd planned on him
coming yeah and then you came but then
right when I saw you I was like oh well
you know you have you know you have a
peaceful nature a thing and that sets
other people at ease yeah it says just
kind of a gift I think you have it's
just a natural thing you have you know
yeah whereas if you roll in with a
couple of [ __ ] neck tats you know
what I'm saying like and you just you
know you wired you can't blink your eyes
even if you try even if you have two
buddies pushing down on the top of each
one
yeah then that a you know I'm I set a
different vibe yeah sure let's take
another call let's hit another call hey
what's up field is david java from
orlando david jolly down in Orlando in
Orlando speaking of Disneyworld and
stuff like that that's where those
families go you get a lot of families on
vacation on the ham yeah yeah yeah I
would say that's definitely a lot uh one
of them one of their demographics I
guess yes yeah sure let's go David Jolly
I had to take the Greyhound I did
see my mama she was in Jacksonville so
you know they green eyes just a lot of
fun a whole lot of fun so I get on that
you know you sit next to the first
single mother you can see Amen habit of
your little shorty nice little rider B I
think it took about four five hours but
let's just say that we had a good time
and it was consensual
well no went back did the Thanksgiving
thing came back on there I try to go for
two-for-one one that lucky the next time
a girl one with the Greyhound is an
amazing place anybody we don't like a
greyhound don't like a good goddamn time
cuz I'm down for the ground Amen boy I'm
down for the ham bruh all aboard david
jolly you know you're right you know we
sit here nothing you know sometimes I
think get the hound ain't the place to
be but what other kind of [ __ ] you want
you could get on the ground
anything could happen you know I'm
saying you could meet the love of your
life you could get molested you could
buy drugs you could uh you can find out
you are the father you know I'm saying
anything could happen you can meet
somebody going to Disney World
you can meet somebody going to prison
where else in America can you have that
so many options in one place
mmm I can't think of a place okay I've
done that trick where you get on a bus
and the first thing you look for there's
just something about a man when they get
on you do kind of if there's a girl
sitting by themself you're not in a
pervert way but you wanna that's nature
sure you want to sit at least you if
they do that sits right next to the girl
that dude is either usually a black dude
is brave enough to do that I'm not brave
enough to do that some black guys I find
are straight-up brave like that you know
they'll sit right next to a girl on a
bus and just immediately like I got to
start a couple rows back yeah it's
slowly move up you know unless I'm that
uh that late bloomer but yeah you
position yourself around that now if a
young girl gets on did you ever get any
Runaways or anything like that that you
saw you thought I mean you want to keep
an eye out for things like that yeah you
definitely see some younger
that me you know not have a stable you
know situation at home or things like
that yeah but I mean as a driver you
know your responsibility isn't to you
know you know pick at everybody's
personal relationship right you want
just make sure everybody's safe
you definitely want to give a safety
speech in the beginning of their bus so
a lot of times drivers will sometimes
give their safety speech as they're just
driving off hey yeah I've heard that
this is this is you know mr. Darryl mr.
Darryl driving off the beer drive from
here to here yeah you know if have any
situation and they just go on a whole
speech what they recommend is to
actually stand up and face your face
your passengers yeah make that eye
contact that's true it does create a
different vibe yeah for sure and you
know that's a lesson really for
everything it's like was the vibe that
you create mm-hmm you know like even
today like you know like and I go back
to said I'm not meaning to but I'm just
trying to relate in a thing like you
know you came and I was like [ __ ] you
know he first he's not gonna come but
then he got here you were late but you
were still you still showed up and but
then you brought your hat you brought
your stuff you know I was like oh wow he
came to play ball you know like he came
you know he showed up like a real like
he act really showed up well I was
excited I'm yeah it may not look like it
man but I'm excited to be here no I'm
excited to have you and I know that you
were nervous man and I probably should
have got on the line within you know
broke it down for you a little bit
better that you know that we weren't
trying to put you in a weird spot or
anything but we just do we've had so
many calls yeah so many really Oh DMS
messages
I had dudes come out to the shows I was
in Tampa last night or New Jersey last
night doing shows and dudes come out and
be like telling me all about that and I
can't wait for the greyhound breakdown
so I said we got a real driver coming in
man you were excited people were excited
yeah let's take another call
gang gang down life trucking man I'm
check-in who is that now is that a
greyhound horn can you tell the horn nah
I can't I wouldn't be able to yeah
sometimes that well there's different
model different buses sometimes you know
yeah
there's not just one bless bus uh you
know that Greyhound uses they use all
kinds of different buses they stick with
a few different models that they use you
ever use uppers to stay up at night do
people take no toes at coffee stuff like
that just coffee man that's it yeah
drink coffee I'll throw a couple uh
where the caffeine shots or whatever
yeah yeah keep you rolling coffee yeah
and you go all night sometimes all night
man
well as a driver though to your
regulated there's a lot of regulations
with your license and things like that
you can only drive so many hours you
know before you need to take that rest
yeah they're fresh again
yeah next call let's hit this hotline so
anyways I'm on the bus I got my [ __ ] I
don't have my means of delivery the
means of delivery is the [ __ ] you
know [ __ ] needle I didn't have it fix
it I needed that [ __ ] to do my supplies
I noticed there's an older gentleman in
front of me okay let's stop it look so
that's a heroin this guy must be a
heroin at it you know and that look
they're everywhere especially these days
you know but this gentleman's sharing a
extensive found heroin experience let's
play more on the heavier side simply ask
them sir are you a diabetic he answered
yes okay so he saw a fat brother he was
a diabetic but it said no but he said
yes I said sir you wouldn't happen to
have an extra syringe he answered yes
that's gonna be $3 dang boom so I'm
running hot I'm going you know made it
all the way from San San Diego Texas I
ran out of supplies hooked up with a
nice guy on the bus he ended up you know
being in the same kind of predicament I
was he also happened to have a little
bit a little bit of that black gold
anyway all things that happened on the
house if you're gonna get your [ __ ]
doctorate in psychology or human
behavior a [ __ ] part of it should be
sticking you on a [ __ ]
transcontinental greyhound
alright traverse the country on the
ground and then you could get your
degree amen and that that should be a
[ __ ] requirement of any doctorate
bachelor's anything Amen praise God dude
now did you ever have something like
that happens to say a man shows up at
the front of the bus
you know he's grammed up but he doesn't
have any syringes any you know
accoutrement you know he don't have that
silverware to serve dinner in his veins
what do you do
can't do much for him man can't do much
fun really like y'all do a collection me
what if you wanted to take a collection
around the bus is he allowed to do that
uh I mean you have free will I mean yeah
I would think you can but um yeah but if
somebody needs to use drugs are there an
attic you guys there's no you know
support you don't service that see
that's I mean no personal no no no that
that's a that's a that's a good point
because I think I think you can probably
ground may need to uh you know
incorporate some type of training for
that yeah I mean different drug problems
and things of that sort
yeah how do you do it because people
have them yeah but that's why Manny got
some help from some other passengers and
you can you could meet anybody let's hit
another call Nick what do we got
hi feel me frigid okay Bridget now did
you ever hit on any of the girls that
got on the hand man no man it was easy
for me man cause like I said you got
your lightning relationship oh you don't
really have to yeah you're good huh yeah
I bet a lot of ladies hit on you though
you're a handsome guy I appreciate that
man but uh yeah yeah yeah sure sure like
a lot of I'm sure a lot of you turn
around and all the girls are sitting by
the front of the bus and every other
seat is open you're like yeah man now
what would you do like say a girl passes
your number just right you just like man
I can't act on that right I can't I
can't act on that what's not I'm not
gonna act a you know like I'm too you
know good or anything like that but uh
ya know you don't sound like that but
yeah what do you do you have a
girlfriend somebody hits on you on the
bus you're running the coach cuz you're
in the position of power yeah you're the
captain you know yeah like I said I
don't know I can't can't do anything
with that you know what I mean but what
do you say I would I would take I would
take the paper piece of paper write a
number and just put on the side yeah
just say thank you or whatever let him
get off and go live their life yeah oh
that's nice appreciate it
yeah something like that yeah cuz you
want yeah you don't want to start
anything either you just wanna let it
exactly right over that let's take
another call has hit that hotline thank
you guys for all these calls and we got
some good ones
let's keep it moving there and there's
this one time and sitting there and
having the open seat next to me and you
hit a stop I said you know door opened
up and a little person walks in and it
reminds you he was he was a black little
person I'll never be honest with you
I've never seen him
she never seen a black little person
it's not like his haha what are you
talking about any like it said to him
rare koala no no it's just a small
brother man she might not know a lot of
liking well because I even grew up in a
town it was like half black half white
and I knew two black little people you
know you know any and I'm probably sure
I'm pretty sure right into a couple but
uh yeah the same I grew up a lot of
around a lot of black people too so yeah
it's not that uncommon maybe she didn't
see it this one dude had these long
dreads he's to trip on his dreads when
you start he didn't wanna like not have
the dress because he didn't want to not
have his style you know but he had these
his heavy-ass dress this boy what's a
[ __ ] guy's name I think is this boy
no Dante was his name and he had these
heavy has dreads he couldn't even get
his head straight up without like
another side would kind of pull it down
but when he would run he had these long
as dredge he would trip on him all the
time look like a [ __ ] dark tumbleweed
he [ __ ] I know but let's hear more
this girl Bridget met her first
all-black little person on a ground and
beautiful stuff can happen on these
coaches onward down here below
everything a great one so he comes any
sickness and he's gone on white wife
beater
from a sport short from timberland boots
the words we're on our way Marin traffic
this thing I know I look over he has his
hands full on in his short shorts and
he's dirty soap off now murder I didn't
know if this is real or not because I
look around nobody else seems to be
reacting and on that week I've been
having some some anxiety and a little
bit of a hallucination so I just thought
well
I guess my mind you put him here you
know now you got a hallucinating white
girl on the Hound she comes up she says
they got a little brother wearin
timberlands okay and she thinks he's
jerking off what do you do what's
protocol amen let's put that up man come
on so it's a Dodger weave huh yeah you
just say look man we got to shut it down
we doing that yeah yeah we doing that
here but you try to defuse a situation
like that
yeah just one make don't make a big deal
out of it shut it down right I respect
that
let's hear more let's hear more because
this girl first of all she says she sees
a small brother you know and she's never
met one okay she's only seeing white
ones which that sounds fake to me and
then she says he's jerking off but she
also says she's been seeing things
recently so maybe her mind just put him
there
oh well really got weird was all of a
sudden he would stop what he was doing
and he would look forward make this
Italian hand gesture and just quietly
argue with no one and then you go right
back at it again so don't what that and
I just kept working 12 o'clock so then
they don't not meet I was driving my
friend found the throat and there he was
oh I think this is a case of who all
seen the Leprechaun say yeah I don't
think she's really seeing uh if she saw
him later that's on a random road you
know did you ever have anybody come up
to the front with hallucinations
probably yeah okay yeah okay we getting
somewhere then all right so that's it
you got to just shut that down if you
see a small brother hallucinating now he
could be on a special route maybe that's
almost like a sasquatch or something you
know people say they see Bigfoot in
certain places you know maybe he's gonna
become like a greyhound lure where I'm a
certain route you see that you know you
get that hit or boy you know little no
Dante out there you know shining up his
little [ __ ] uh shining up his little
shell-shocked ER let's hear more what
else we got all the Christmas he brought
in Lafayette is useful it's not like
solid baby Dookie every other term is
just not like normal year but on that
surface it
every time we made a stop a homeless
person would come and act everybody on
the bus of money and I remember one of
the homeless people
Gandhi was wearing a hospital gown
the big black lady and the back of the
hospital gown was wide open it's all you
seen it was big black booty don't like
that's me horrific for me devour the key
and now the first booty everything
without my mama's dang so a lot of first
can happen on the hand huh yeah you see
people on a vacation going to see like a
first trip yeah yeah yeah what's the
most beautiful thing you ever seen
happen on a route man you ever seen
anybody get engaged or anything like
that anything come to mind no not at the
time I had man but uh a lot of first
time just right or some people are you
know too too nervous or too scared to
fly the plane so that's the only means
of transportation is you know they want
to take a bus because they can't fly do
my but are charter sponsor actually used
this company great block pizza and they
they're at eighteen eleven Pico
Boulevard over there near the beach but
their owner and creator Thomas who has
he has a new podcast called mob rats if
you get to check it out it's about young
business guys in Los Angeles and how
they are living their lives and moving
forward I think I got to listen to some
more episodes but he's afraid to fly so
he's like I mean he had a a cousin came
and got with him he's afraid to even
drive long distances so he had a cousin
recent thing came and picked him and try
to drive him up to Oregon yeah he's got
some family up there and he couldn't
even make he made it like to Fresno and
how to turn around yeah like he can't
even yeah you know I guess some people
have some real fears of traveling yeah
yeah driving isn't for everybody either
you know like I think kind of runs in my
blood my dad's uh my dad was a driver
oh really yeah he was truck driver huh
you ever go ride with him he took me on
a couple trips I was real small that's
cool though so I don't know if I just
picked that up on my own or he's I don't
know it might just be in my blood but
yeah
yeah that's interesting maybe maybe you
just remember that being with him one
time as a comfort set inside of you and
you like doing it yeah yeah I remember
him just teaching me I when I was
younger all the time you know just teach
me everything and if you retired now or
no no no he still works
oh nice to me I used to work let's go
more Nick what do we got we got any more
calls when I was real little I think
probably maybe 7 or 8 years old a woman
young woman she was maybe you know 17 18
years old she was giving me what I
thought were you know party balloons but
actually they were they were condoms she
was blowing up condoms and handed them
to me and I was with my older brother at
the time he had to kind of get me away
from this woman another time maybe this
is a clown brother this isn't freaking
that's clown practice man let me blowing
up condoms and passing him out to kids
man that's chill did he say this is
anything with great honor no I was on a
greyhound okay let's hear more Lee maybe
about ten years ago I was on the
greyhound and there's a lot of convict
there's a lot of prisoners just getting
out of prison and I was there to witness
you know a guy just got out of prison
and a young woman you know pleasured him
orally in the bathroom you know and I
thought that was you know really kind of
her and sort of a nice touch and
actually the screen if I'm being real
cool got me a little bit excited you
know ultimately I think grant you know
there's like Humanity on the bus man
yeah and as true mean I guess if you're
a lady and you want to do like a
first-time thing or anything to find out
a manager's been in prison I think
there's probably a conquest that comes
for a woman you know like oh I get to
you know like this man hasn't been with
a woman in 15 years yeah so I'm a
pleasure him I'm gonna you know treat
him right right you know I could see
that happening I had a dude yeah one
time is dude on the Greyhound while this
woman was asleep got in her luggage put
on all of her [ __ ] clothes dude and
then sat there across from home when she
[ __ ] woke up yeah another do one time
had ants all over them like probably
seventy thousand ants I cuz I like he
was asleep and he just said ants going
all over
so he had his own little you know his
own little colony style skin what else
man what's happy oh this is happy Marsh
so when I was 15
oh [ __ ] little lady calling you think
our young man she said her name was
happy Marcy happy Marcy there we go just
happy Marcy Collin she's been uh and
she's going home before thanks for going
home Marcy let's go he and I decided you
know I ran away from home and I'm I'm
gonna take a trip up to Albany New York
to go stay with my sister and the middle
of the night in the middle of nowhere
I'm sleeping and I'm 15 years old and I
was probably about 12 so I'm sleeping
and the guy next to me drunk as a skunk
I just remember that he had a class with
them all and that he had been drinking
all night for about 1:00 2:00 in the
morning I wake up to somebody just
fondling my leg and I look over my eyes
and there he is drunk breath all up in
my face as a midnight man I excused
myself with his hand out of way excuse
myself get up I go up to the front
tell the driver that this gentleman was
fondling my leg and who knows what else
while I was sleeping and so the bus
driver pulls over in the middle of
nowhere we are miles from anywhere miles
from even a rest up and he cause the guy
to get that hell off of the bus he
radios in for the Highway Patrol to come
pick him up and he completing their
little nowhere Wow sayonara oh she got
Japanese at the end there and is that
protocol what's protocol there man
protocol for something like that sounds
about right yep that sounds about right
gotta go yeah none of that she's
underage you know yeah man can't have
that so we can't have that man it's
protocol you off the bus boy thanks for
going on Nick let's take a nothing on
this Greyhound breakdown and this is the
last one we got to all right this is the
last one let's hear one more here on
hell coming in on that home stretch here
you put on the Hat for the home stretch
on help let's get that right back on its
rightful owner baby
I feel this is Evan from there we go boy
and you can even put them like this if
you need to whatever gets it done for
you there you go
yeah there you go whatever is good what
we got there Nikki hey Theo this is Evan
from Arizona okay this is Evan from
Arizona thanks for calling Evan I was in
Cleveland and Greyhound station waiting
for the bus waiting for the Hat okay
that's a tough mix right there Cleveland
and Greyhound bruh anything is possible
anything is possible this could be the
Big Kahuna let's go now and a man stood
up and just vomited just puked all over
right in the middle of the station and
the employees nobody really gave up oh
that's that nobody cared that's not
vegan fourth of July right there brother
when somebody stands up everybody that's
a vegan fourth of July baby what else
happened man as they do and they just
kind of covered it up with floor mat
instead of cleaning it yep and then when
anybody would come in there wasn't
already in there to witness that they
would kind of step on that floor mat and
you can see on their faces their order
and where that awful smell was coming
from so uh a little comical little
disgusting totally greyhound amen
brother it sounds like and where was he
going he said in Arizona yeah I didn't
say where his destination was but we can
assume in the air at Cleveland Arizona
yeah yeah man so I guess it would not
win it no motor coach is going and
something like that happens was protocol
there you just you got to keep moving
huh uh if a passenger throws up like
that yeah yeah you got to pull over and
that's that's a clean up unfortunately
is that take a while yeah I mean there's
cleaning supplies on the bus you know
did you have to do a lot of that was a
lot of cleanup so everything was usually
yeah oh I've had my fair share of
cleanup sometimes you can't get to a
station that does look a lot of major
stations have cleaners yeah
and you know they go through and clean
up the bus and everything for example
like say you're going to pour it
Portland okay for Portland you'll stop
in and coming from Los Angeles you
probably make a stop in Sacramento
uh-huh sometimes if that bus is going is
gonna stay with the same group of
passengers and that bus is going all the
way up to Portland they will they will
clean all the bus keep all of the
passengers possessions or luggage
everything that's on the bus in the same
spot and do a clean up but if if you're
in the middle of the road and something
like that happens as a coach operator
you definitely have to probably clean
that up yeah yeah you got to respond
yeah yeah I've had my fair share of that
too
have you had a lot of coach operators
that knock up passenger anything like
that it started a family with a
passenger you hear any wild stuff like
that I think so I think I a couple of a
couple drivers may have started a
relationship with a bouncer sure oh yeah
yeah that's life huh yeah I think that
one thing that just seems to happen on
Greyhound is just life huh it was life
it's learning real on there yeah it is
is it's it's it's uh you just handle
each situation as it happens you know
you just got to be prepared though too
for anything yeah yeah was it ever scary
or no um it gets a little bit uh I
wouldn't say a little bit scary a little
nervous you know
you drive it far away you know you're
far from home far from your family so
yeah that definitely plays into into a
driver you know especially being so
young yeah yeah do you feel like you'll
always be a driver no I have greater
aspirations man oh not that it's a bad
aspiration I don't mean do you think I
meant that uh like like what do you mean
by always be a driver do you feel like
it's something you will always do you
know like um like perfect like for a
living to make yeah or somewhat yeah
maybe maybe but um yeah I mean I like I
said I do have I'm a driver now right
now it's going pretty good
you're still pretty young 26 you said
yeah I'm 26 I'm just I'm just getting my
experience in how about about going on
six years driving
experience I started off as a school bus
driver really yeah dude if I got on my
school like there were kids that were
older than you in my middle school we
had a 22 year old dude in our middle
school named mr. Larry right mr. and his
big trick was if you were peeing at the
urinal and this is in fourth grade or
fifth grade he'd come in behind yous 22
right he would piss over you into the
urinal she would be like what's
happening you know yeah and it was
always exciting and scary you know but
um dude yeah I can't believe if I got on
a [ __ ] school bus even now at 26 if
at 21 is Bobby you were the driver yeah
I'd be like let's take this bus to the
[ __ ] French Quarter let's take this
to Bourbon Street we're not going to
school right I know
Allah I know a lot uh even now I work
also part-time as an on-call school bus
driver now I don't really work too many
hours for it for a school district but
you know as a substitute school bus
driver sometimes you get those kids that
try to you know test you or try to you
know fill you out a little bit ya know
oh oh yeah and what's tougher driving a
bus full of school kids or running a
Greyhound coach and why they both have
their challenges for sure
kids can I mean you'd be surprised
junior high kids especially how you know
they're growing up now they get exposed
to so much they know a lot of different
things the way they talk you know can be
challenging their vote their you know
their voices can be loud distracting
things off yeah yeah but sometimes you
get on the greyhound end and you're
going through a midnight driving this
everybody's asleep you know or it's just
real quiet
yeah real quiet so they both have their
challenges yeah it seemed like the kids
would even be tough perfect yeah I guess
you can yeah a little bit feel more
responsibility when you're driving the
kids or when you're driving great and
equal equal just as a driver you're just
really responsible for for them all
equal to be honest with you yeah what's
interesting as I'm here you talk as if
it seemed like it's just the ability to
be a driver is kind of a thing like I
just don't know if I would have the pay
since and the you know that I don't know
if it's the general care for others but
I guess probably the patient's I don't
know if I would have the patience for it
you know help me takes a lot of patience
huh for sure a lot of patience yeah yeah
because you know and you don't realize
that as a passion you don't realize that
there's someone who is you know it has
to keep a level head mm-hmm for
everybody yeah very short because if I
think one of the great attributes as a
driver is just the ability to stay calm
I think if you know because you run into
all kinds of things whether it be the
passenger problems or even just driving
on the road people cutting you off
traffic all that plays into into into
how you handle that bus yeah you know
health if you're not a healthy driver
you're not eating right if you're you
know eating a lot of fatty foods which
which is very common as a driver oh yeah
as a traveler when you're traveling it's
hard to eat well exactly so you start
getting waste you know all that plays in
the fact are on on being a driver so a
lot of different factors I guess not a
lot of people really consider or think
about yeah when you know when traveling
so I don't think it just takes a piece
of mind it takes some patience it takes
a level of you know
yeah just of severe patients with
humanity yeah because I mean as a ground
driver space like taking the DMV mm-hmm
in the traffic it's like you know I'm
gonna take a [ __ ] to hit baby
yeah and I'm I had a couple of babies
couple grams you know and take his [ __ ]
right up in the road and it's just
fearless man yeah you know what it's
admirable I think I'm gonna have a
different you know it's cool now I feel
like I kind of know a motorcoach
operator that's cool you know so to give
me like a little bit of a different
perspective when I you know go on next
time you know I can say hey my man on
Hills a motorcoach operator I heard it's
pretty you know I heard it's pretty much
everything yeah yeah for sure man
appreciate that do well good luck with
your lady man I commits commendable 10
years you know that's nice there's tough
to say though is it tough to hold the
line in a relationship yes is it yeah
what
what some of the biggest challenges that
you find um biggest challenges I think
just growth you know as we grow we met
when we were kids basically yeah like 15
15 16 years old getting together
freshman year of high school Wow but
yeah just growth just learning to adapt
and you know be a little bit
compromising you know yeah we have
problems all the time but you know you
just work through it
talk talk talk about it with something
nicest she does let you know that she
cares about you oh she does a lot man
she does a lot just from the small
things just cleaning even just cleaning
you know just clean the apartment or
taking care of my son she's a great mom
yeah I give a lot of credit to her so
yeah is it her child yes yeah yeah okay
yeah yeah just making sure how I assumed
it was based on the year yeah if you'd
have been like nah yeah this dude's been
uh this days been you know all aboard
for sure thanks so much on how I
appreciate you coming in man thank you
will you connect this mate with another
driver we might do another Greyhound
breakdown in another couple of months or
something our listeners have been bro
the stories that came in you know the
excitement I mean it was just
fascinating yeah you know you might have
you see maybe in the future you connect
us with somebody okay and we'll see if
we can't do something nice for them in
return you know as a gift for them for
coming out awesome
yeah dude thank you so much man any last
words for our listeners brah um I know a
lot of times ground get a bad rap but uh
you know just hang in there
yeah hang in there and hopefully
everything would be get to your
destination safe I like him and what
type of speech do you give the people
you when you when you step onto the
coach when you give oh man I have a
whole speech I go through man you do
yeah how long is it a couple minutes you
want to give a little bit of it you know
but harder now uh
yeah let's give it on the way out I
don't think we need to here this is
something everybody needs to hear I'll
be a passenger all right okay all right
so can we leave where's our destination
Theo our destination today is we are
headed to Sedona Arizona Sedona Arizona
yep okay all righty everybody first of
all thank you guys for riding with
Greyhound bus lines my name is angel I
will be your driver from downtown Los
Angeles to Sedona Arizona a few safety
things guys well while we're traveling
on this bus these safety exits here I
got to do is pull on this red lever push
out in case you need to get on emergency
the restroom located in the rear make
sure you guys hold on to the make sure
you guys hold on to the handrail located
above the seats while you while the bus
is in motion making sure not to fall
especially while the bus is in motion
I don't mind you guys having
conversations while the bus is in motion
just keep try to keep your conversation
to a volume to a minimum as I will be
concentrating on driving amen
these buses are equipped with seat belts
so at this time I might ask you to put
on your seat belt do amen buckle it
safety first yeah and and there's also a
trash bag located here so if you guys
need to put any of your trash I greatly
appreciate it if you know put your
guys's trash in there
other than that let's have a safe trip
once again my name is angel if you have
any other questions please ask me our
next up next up so don't Arizona amen
that's it huh all aboard
angel thank you so much for coming in
man Thank You Man and uh and thanks for
going down guys if you have any other
great stories good or bad love stories
anything hit us up nine eight five six
six four nine five zero three and let's
give a big round of applause for angel
for that first gray hair breakdown and
we'll see you guys next time
some [ __ ] right now
[Music]